antennes relais téléphone sans fil et
portables micro-ondes bornes wifi ou
encore ampoules basse consommation sont
devenus un calvaire pour stéphane loriot
souffrant d'électro sensibilité du coût
d'installation d'antennes relais dans
mon quartier il ya plus de dix ans les
premiers insomnies ce mettait déjà en
place les migraines constante et après
toute la panoplie avec le wifi qui se
rajoutent rapidement par la suite le
wifi ça ma pauvre il s'est demandé au
tout départ après une sensation de
l'enfoncement de la cage thoracique une
douleur au coeur de l'eczéma qui
appareil qui repart sur sur mon visage
ces symptômes se transforme en véritable
handicap à gérer dans son activité
professionnelle
quand vous avez des trous de mémoire
quand votre machine de travail c'est la
mémoire et la parole et que vous devenez
bègue
je peux vous garantir qu'avant chaque
prestation toutes ces petites choses qui
sont sur cette table là sont
incontournables obligatoire le tanakan
les baies de goji et la sauge c'est la
base
lortie qui sont évidemment bc3 ces trois
ingrédients je me dois de les prendre
pour ne pas bégayer pour avoir un esprit
éclairé enfin bref savoir un petit
format ne veut pas taquiner vers le
alzheimer tout de suite officiellement
diagnostiqué intolérants aux ondes en
il a fait aménager son bureau au château
de la madeleine à chevreuse pour être à
l'abri des sources électromagnétiques
son espace de travail est tapissé de
rideau en fibres d'argent une matière
qui diminue l'intensité des ondes grâce
à ce certificat effectivement j'ai pu
obtenir par ma hiérarchie l'autorisation
de poser ses rideaux fils d'argent qui
coûte tout de même la bagatelle de 600
euros payés grâce à vos impôts s'il vous
plaît il insistait pour ce soit le cas
pour qu'on puisse dans le milieu du
travail déjà fait relancer un peu le
dossier stéphane loriot assure ne pas
être un cas isolé et prête volontiers
son polio m qui capte les champs
électromagnétiques
ambiance mais pour une prise de
conscience collective des risques selon
lui il reste du chemin à parcourir
il continue donc de militer au sein de
l'association harpe un chevreuse